hallo mein name ist klug herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf einem kanal beziehungsweise
nicht nur zu einem neuen didier sondern
zu einer neuen serie lukas neue stunde
lukas leute stunde
hey
beschissen ist das intro in ganz
deutschland aber ich allerdings erst
noch zu erklären was lukas noll stunde
überhaupt ist
ich habe euch vor einer woche in einer
instagram story von mir gesagt und das
tier einfach ihnen welche videos wo er
einen witz auf sagt oder voll ist
einfach unter dem hashtag luca lauf
instagram kostet und da wurde wirklich
eine menge geistiger dünnschiss
hochgeladen in der tat meine freundin
hat 30 von diesen witz videos sag ich
mal sich runtergeladen mir auf einer sd
karte gegeben und wir reagieren nun live
auf diese witze von euch und ehrlich
sogar pizza margherita hat mit hopps zu
ja
als gott die erde shoot gesagt hätten
ihr bei der schöne gehorsam und
talentierte frauen in allen ecken der
welt sind dann macht er die erde rund
und lachte
wow
sie hat sich einfach gerade selbst
gelöst was ist der unterschied zwischen
einen polen und einen arzt
der pole weiß was sie fehlt das
bescheuerte ist sie ist sogar polen das
halt oberschenkel beinbruch bei japanern
knick knack in nagasaki humor level ist
echt ja das einfach nicht vorhanden ich
wollte kegel aber dieser wollte bullshit
ich will mir einfach ich die augen
auskratzen nach sagen die leute wie
nikab ist scheiße
die flasche ist ausgelaufen da musste
ich kurz machen was machen tiere in der
disco
[Musik]
diskutieren
stark deshalb minecraft spielt nebenbei
essen autos vom liebsten richtig paar
plätzchen
888 ducati der witz war ja weil komplett
schlecht ich weiß ich warum ich trotzdem
darüber lache das ding ist
sie rettet das ganze jetzt noch erste
zwölfter luca - shop.de lehrerin frau
klasse erster zwölfter freunde kommt in
lucka - shop.de eine neue kollektion
klamotten fünf neue sachen und morgen am
black friday gibt es sogar 33 prozent
auf alles also wenn ihr noch was altes
kaufen wollt aus meinem shop macht das
morgen warum kleine russin inna zwei
autos auf einmal auf der flucht müssen
sie noch einmal durch polen
decker diese polen
ich glaube die hat echt was gegen ihre
heimat was ist die lustigste automarke
der welt ein scherz jedes
mercedes
alter hahaha war den schlecht aber nicht
so schlecht wie luca
ich hab echt
die beschissene community der welt
das
was los sei geht eine schwangere
bäckerei und sage ich krieg ein brot
sagt der bäcker lustig sachen die gibt
wenn finden fand ich noch nie lustig
sagte lehrer zu schieben wäre die
nächste frage richtig beantwortet davon
montag zu hause bleiben haben wir dann
stift noch von lehrer werten stiftet
aufgeschossenen tom ich bis dienstag
ist ok
es ist wirklich okay immer wieder geht
es um einerseits stellt fest dass die
thüringer bekommt sie kann plötzlich an
zu weinen in der abstraktion warum ich
habe doch nur einmal warum habe ich
schon zwei kinder
wow wow wow
mein ganzes leben sie gerade an mir
vorbei das macht einen so ist ich meine
wenn ich jemand haften muss trotzdem
ich hasse diese neue serie jetzt schon
ich hätte gerne zwei kilo kartoffeln
aber wird die kleine damit ich nicht so
viel tragen
es gab bisher keinen witz wo ich einfach
loslassen musste aber vielleicht jetzt
beim nächsten witz was trägt eine
blondine
wenn ihr computer brennt die löschtaste
komplett scheiße was krieg ein land mit
zwei linken füßen 5 lit
da lacht
wenn ich schlafen ins kino juli sagte
kinoticket verkäuferin
ich hätte gerne zwei karten bringt die
kinotickets verkäuferin für den hobbit
sagt julia
das ist mein freund er war gemeint aber
stark über tatsächlich noch zwei weitere
witze unter dem hashtag luca lauf
instagram gepostet das heißt mal schauen
ob die auch gut zwei wochen in den
keller sagt eine bombe zu anderen
eigentlich hochgehen
china mit einem fetten com crafter
konfetti
ich hatte echt vertrauen in ihn nach dem
ersten witze
der das vertrauen
mit füßen getreten aber ich meine komm
ich geb dir noch eine letzte chance ein
zwei waschmaschinen die treppe runter
die eine waschmaschine geht kaputt die
anderen nicht warum geht ihr an nach
waschmaschinen stoffen
ja warum
[Musik]
decker
letztlich in der branche
und denk dir keine witze mehr aus was
ist der unterschied zwischen einem
vegetarischen worden vegetarisch der
eine ist ein reich wolf der andreasen
fleischwolf
ich würde mir am liebsten gerade dieses
mikrofon ganz tief in meinem gehirn ist
die befehls form von schweigen
seit der schüler das war das lustigste
dass ich heute gehört das badewasser
lauchsuppe
ist
ja ist die wahrheit
ein junge und ein mädchen die zusammen
sind ihnen in ein kino die verknüpfung
fragt ob konsums oder 60er genau wie
meine freundin verkäuferin jedoch sagte
sorry hässliche popcorn haben wir hier
nicht
ich weiß nicht warum ich dann sonntag
einfach wieder lustig bin also der du
hast frau wir wie sehr er witz des tages
medaille erhalten
er ruft mich eine familie ab und bildet
sich möglich stellte ihnen komme und
hier in ihre klinge repariere ich fahre
also mit schnell hin leute und leute und
sonst keiner macht auch das war
ein anrufer hatte kein netz
der gehabt ihr die witze von eurer uroma
das passiert
gleichzeitig gehe und cola trinkt man
kollabiert
welchen spruch und einen helm liebsten
maria bord was
was rosen sind münzen sind geld ich habe
mir eine pizza bestellt so kommt er
liegt noch mit peter ramsauer
diese das hier
schade ein veganer mit durchfall
smoothie maker
noch 33 würze noch was auch bei uns von
unserer polnischen freunde ein pole und
ein russe alle drei sitzen im auto wäre
es wert das auto ein polizist
[Musik]
oder beinen um die häuser ziehen das ist
so ein süßes geben
und dann erzählt er mir
viele hunde oder beide um die häuser
zieht tom wir nun allerdings meine damen
und herren hier heute zum letzten sitz
dem juli mir ausgesucht hat ich würde
sagen im film ab für den job quer luca
auf dem fahrrad sitzt man ihn ein konrad
[Musik]